One important element in making a virtual world seem real is collision
detection and response. Collision detection is just that, you detect whether
two objects have moved such that they overlap. Even modest forms of collision
detection can make a user feel that they're in a virtual world instead of a
ghost that can pass through anything. For example, simply shooting a ray from
the user's location and finding the distance to the closest intersection will
reveal whether the user's position should be adjusted. Where the problem begins
to get complex is when you have many objects in a scene. With a brute force
approach you compare everything to everything else for collision. Much of the
efficient collision detection coding is in creating data structures that
quickly call out possible collisions that can't occur in a frame. The other
half of the problem is collision response, what to do when two objects are
found to have collided. This depends on a number of variables, including the
velocity of the objects, and in this case, the elasticity of the materials.
Collision detection is done primarily on the CPU in most programs at this
point, though there have been some moves to off load the work to the GPU, or
even custom chips. This is a complex subject, entire books have been written
about it, but this is all we'll cover here.